president biden is under pressure from
his own party this morning to respond
and respond strongly to the supreme
court's action but he's overseas at the
moment for the latest g7 summit in
germany and that's where we find ed
o'keefe traveling with the president he
joins us now from austria edits early
but everyone's wondering what does this
mean politically
well tony good morning from the g7
summit where the president's focused on
his international agenda even though he
and his party are facing fallout from
the supreme court ruling there is at
least some encouraging short-term
political gain potentially for democrats
in all of this look at our new cbs news
poll that finds 50 percent of registered
democrats say the court's decision makes
them more likely to vote this fall the
kind of boost of enthusiasm the party's
going to need up and down the ballot the
poll also finds majority support for
congress passing a federal law to
legalize abortion rights nationwide
that's now quickly become a key
democratic party campaign pledge the
president's facing pressure from fellow
democrats to more forcefully respond to
the ruling progressives like senator
elizabeth warren once again over the
weekend calling to add more justices to
the supreme court and to get rid of the
senate filibuster to make it easier to
pass democratic priorities but the white
house says the president doesn't support
expanding the size of the high court
here in europe president biden says none
of the world leaders he's been meeting
with have mentioned the abortion ruling
to him even though many of them
criticized it in the hours after the
court weighed in last week here at the
summit today the focus is on unity
around ukraine the leaders heard
virtually earlier today from ukraine's
president zielinski gail
thank you very much ed o'keefe reporting
from australia austria